[LOGO MUSIC]
DANIEL BERGQVIST: Hi, everyone.
I'm Daniel.
BILLY JACOBSON: And I'm Billy.
And we're from the Google
Cloud developer relations team.
Our focus is on storage, and
especially Cloud based storage.
DANIEL BERGQVIST:
We want to help
you make informed decisions
about what storage solution
to use for your IoT project.
We're going to start
off by discussing
a little bit about the shape,
size, and scale of the data.
Every industry has
unique data problems,
and we're going to focus
on the kinds of problems
that you might see when
building IoT apps at scale.
BILLY JACOBSON:
Then we'll see why
the Cloud is a great fit for
data of this shape and scale.
And we'll look at how to ingest
your data into the Cloud.
DANIEL BERGQVIST: We
look into a number
of storage
characteristics that you
need to take into
consideration when reasoning
about storage solutions.
BILLY JACOBSON:
And, finally, we'll
examine a few common use
cases, and real world scenarios
that businesses encounter.
We'll map those business
needs to technical storage
requirements, and
then select a database
based on that information.
And we've got a few cool demos
for you to check out today.
DANIEL BERGQVIST: So this
is a storage [INAUDIBLE]
although, with a little
bit of a Cloud twist.
And one of the first
things that comes to mind,
when we think about storage,
is how much data can I store?
This is a relevant
question, especially
in the way with an
IoT use case in mind.
Connected devices today produce
massive amounts of data.
According to
statistics, there will
be 50 billion connected
devices by 2023.
So this is a map of oil and gas
fields in the Gulf of Mexico.
Let's do a thought experiment.
Let's say that we have
1,300 oil and gas fields,
and each oil and gas field has
1,000 sensors streaming data.
Even if those devices is only
streaming 100 bytes per second,
that still makes 137 megabytes
per second, in total.
Or over eight
gigabytes per minute.
Or 11.5 terabytes a day.
You could try to manage that
the infrastructure on your own.
But there's a reason
the Cloud exists.
All the infrastructure
headaches that
comes with managing
massive amounts of data
is minimized by using the Cloud.
So let's make sure we
are on the same page,
here, when we talk
about IoT data.
What we really mean, when
we talk about IoT data,
is time series data.
Some of the common requirements
for storing time series data
include robustness.
For some applications, data
loss simply cannot happen.
We want high volumes,
reads, and writes.
And we want low latency to
go with these high volumes
of reads or writes.
We want to have efficient ways
of backfill, historical data.
And we want efficient
sequential reads.
The connected devices.
The producers of the
data we are talking about
could be anything from
smart home appliances,
to public transit cards.
Whether you're starting
with 10 devices, or 10,000,
using the Cloud to manage
your device's storage
and analytical tooling
provides security, reliability,
and scale.
I will now hand
it over to Billy,
and he will talk a little
bit about Cloud IoT Core.
BILLY JACOBSON:
Cool, thanks, Daniel.
So, yeah, our Cloud based
solution for this is IoT Core.
And you get secure
connections, easy ways
to manage your devices, and
all of this is at global scale.
We've got IoT Core.
And then this breaks
down into registries,
which are the buckets that
hold your individual devices.
From there, the registries
will automatically
connect and publish messages
to a Cloud Pub/Sub topic.
And Cloud Pub/Sub is our
event stream manager,
that will allow your
IoT pipelines to scale.
You get fine grained
access controls,
end to end encryption,
and at least one delivery,
to ensure a reliable and
secure streaming of data
in a fully managed service.
And all of this is global
by default. Publish
from anywhere in the world
and consume from anywhere.
With consistent latency, no
replication is necessary.
From there, Pub/Sub
integrates perfectly
with Cloud Dataflow, our
fully managed stream and batch
data processing tool.
And you can use this with the
open source Apache Beam SDK.
You can subscribe
to the Pub/Sub topic
and then run your ETL
operations on these messages.
So this is our IoT
pipeline so far.
Set of your devices on IoT core.
They'll send
messages to Pub/Sub,
and then your data
flow BPEL Process it.
It works great with
a handful of devices,
and scales up to handle
1,000 megabytes per second.
When we think back
to the example
Daniel just showed of
those oil and gas fields
around the Gulf of Mexico,
that could only produce around
15% of what this can handle.
So this pipeline can
really handle a lot,
just to kind of give
you that idea for scale.
So we'll take the
standard IoT pipeline.
And then this is
the part where you
need to make a decision,
choosing a storage
solution for your data.
Every database has
strengths, and you
have to make
trade-offs to ensure
you're using the database
best fit for your use case.
Daniel's going to talk
about the features
we'll find in various databases,
and what kinds of limitations
you might run in to, as well.
All right, here you go.
DANIEL BERGQVIST:
Thank you, Billy.
As Billy showed in
the previous slide,
the ingestion pipeline is
pretty standardized the moving
part here is storage.
So in this section,
we'll talk a little bit
about the different
characteristics
that databases might have.
Databases that, on the surface,
will look pretty similar.
So if this is too basic for some
of you, we apologize for that.
But we think it's important that
everybody is on the same page
before moving on.
So we tried to group the
deciding factors for your story
solution into three pillars.
Functionality, such as data
model, query languages,
partitioning, et cetera.
Scalability, which,
in the IoT world,
always will be the
deciding factor.
And lastly, cost.
Let's see if this
makes sense to.
So there are many
types of data models.
Just look at, like,
many books there
are on data normalization,
or stuff like that.
And every data model comes
with assumptions about how
it's going to be used.
Since the data model has such
a profound effect on what
the application can
do, or cannot do,
it's super important to
choose one that is appropriate
for your use case.
A good practice is to
lay out the queries
that you want to
be able to perform
on your data ahead of time.
That will give you
a great insights
in what data model to use.
The relational model
does a very good job
of mind hiding
implementation details
behind a clean interface.
However, the use cases we are
looking at, other data models
might be a much better fit.
Let me give you a few examples.
So we usually need
greater scalability
than what relational databases
easily can achieve, especially
when it comes to
very large data sets
or very high write throughput.
A desire for more
flexible schema design,
or a more expressive data model.
For example, schema read
instead of schema write.
So many people feel that a
declarative language, like SQL,
is much easier to work
with than an imperative
one like JavaScript.
And as we've
discussed previously,
the relational model,
and subsequently, SQL,
does a really good job of
hiding implementation details
of the database engine.
So that means that
the database vendor
can introduce performance
improvements under the hood
without you having to
change any of your queries.
On the other hand, many
non-relational database that
support specialized
query operations
that might fit our use
case much, much better.
One example would be
efficient sequential reads.
In a distributed
system, first, we
might just address the
terminal logical confusion,
that this is all
the same things.
It's just what
different databases call
charting or partitioning or
regions or tablets and whatnot.
But in a distributed
system, data
will always be partitioned.
So when you have a system
with data partitioned
over several nodes, how will you
go about scaling your cluster
up and down, as more nodes
get added to the cluster?
Will the database help you
reassign data to new nodes,
or is that something that
you'll have to manage yourself?
And if you have to
manage it yourself,
will that make you
have to compromise
on your scalability goals?
In some systems,
assigning ownership
of a partition to a new node
is a online metadata operation
that doesn't require
any data motion.
Spoiler alert, I think
Billy will talk about one
of these systems
in a little bit.
So, replication.
Replication basically
means that we
are keeping a copy of the
same data on multiple nodes,
on multiple machines.
There are several
reasons why you might
like your data replicated.
So, for once, you
maybe want to make sure
that your data is graphically
close to your users.
Another one could be for
high availability reasons.
Maybe you want to increase
your throughput by adding
additional read replicas.
Or maybe you want to do it
for workload separation.
You might have one
cluster serving data,
and an identical cluster for
your analytical workloads.
And lastly, cost.
So how is the database licence?
Is it open source?
Does the provider charge
you for the amount
of data that your store, or for
the throughput that you get?
Or something else?
Is it a managed service?
Do you need to take on
management and monitoring
of the database?
And if so, how do you
quantify that cost?
What does support cost?
Do you have the competence
for this technology in-house,
or do you need to
train people on it?
We did it.
Hopefully, we are on
the same page, now,
and have a common language.
So if there's one thing
we want you to take away
from this session, it
is don't treat storage
as an afterthought.
So we've identified two
different iota use cases.
The first one we call
complex application logic.
This is where the read to
write ratio is balanced.
These applications are not
just about receiving data
from devices, but also
controlling the devices.
So the complex
application logic is
used to determine some
kind of change that needs
to be performed on the device.
The other type of application
that we've identified
is something we called
data ingestion intensive.
Here, we have many devices
sending a lot of data upstream.
These applications are
write intensive, as
opposed to read intensive.
And they are usually used
for monitoring or analytics.
With that said, let's
look at a few scenarios.
The first scenario, we will look
at a newly founded IoT startup.
The IoT startup is still in
the beginning of their journey,
so the team is still small.
They have developed a platform
for smart home appliances
like light bulbs, thermostats,
smoke detectors, et cetera.
The data from each
smart home appliance
is very suitable to be stored
as a self-contained document.
And the smart home
appliances are being
controlled by mobile apps.
So a family, for
example, can have
several mobile apps that are
controlling these appliances.
So let's map these two
to technical features.
Small team and
limited resources.
Most company would probably
benefit from serverless today,
but, for a small startup, it
might be absolutely crucial.
If you have a small
team of developers,
letting them focus
on your core business
instead of managing servers
could make all the difference.
Self-contained documents
sounds like something
that would be a good fit
for a document database.
The hierarchical structure lends
itself to good data locality.
And the fact that there
is mobile apps that
are being used to
control the appliances
gives us a hint that this is a
complex application logic case.
So this would be closer to
the first of the two use
cases we discussed earlier.
So this startup, they don't
only face the challenges of IoT,
they also have to
manage mobile apps.
So let's have a
quick look what it
would take to build a mobile
database the hard way.
First, you need a
database service
like MySQL, Postgres or Mongo.
And you've got to manage and
scale that database yourself.
Then you want to query
the database from afar.
So you need an API layer.
And that API layer needs
to be able to authenticate
and authorize your queries.
And finally, you need
to keep state locally.
And that requires
yet, another database.
And that database has to be kept
in sync with the remote one.
So that's a lot of stuff to do.
And that's only to
fetch some simple data.
And I mean, let's
not even get started
on what it would
take to make that
a real time system, instead
of a [INAUDIBLE] one.
Let's see how we
can simplify this.
Enter Firestore.
How many in here are
familiar with Firestone?
That's pretty good.
So Firestore is what we
call a serverless database.
So serverless doesn't mean
that there are no servers, what
it means is that everything from
capacity planning, upgrades,
maintenance, all of that
is handled seamlessly
by the system without
scheduled downtime.
Multi-region replication, we
keep your app and user data
safe and available
across regions--
in case of disaster--
without any configuration
on your side.
Firestore is a globally
distributed database that
will scale based on your usage.
Cloud Firestore lets
us structure our data
as collection and
documents, which
makes queries much easier.
We can store related data
together in hierarchies.
We based this model on what we
learned from Firebase Realtime
Database developers.
We studied how people
wanted to model their data,
supporting the most common
use cases with patents
that most developers
designed intuitively.
So far, we noticed that this
reduces the learning curve,
and that the data model
is designed to scale.
Let's look at
Firestore in action.
So can we switch to
the demo, please?
This is actually super
good, this is a live demo.
But we have the creator of
the demo in the audience.
So if stuff goes
sideways, you know?
So we have four quadrants here,
forming the Firebase logo.
And then we have 40,000
clients that we have simulated.
And 10,000 clients are assigned
to each of the quadrants.
So what we do here, is that
all these 10,000 clients,
they are listening to
one of these inputs.
So, of course, no
one will get upset.
We do zero based indexing here.
So this is zero.
This is one.
This is two.
And it is three.
So 10,000 is listening to
each of these four documents.
When they see a
change, they will then
write that change back
into this collection,
which is called pixels.
And these are then 40,000
different documents.
So, when we do a change on one
of the documents over here,
that will trigger 10,000 reads
from one document, and 10,000
writes to different documents.
And, hopefully, it will also
change the color of this.
So, if we take this one
and we change the color,
like this, to red--
and now it should--
there you go.
So we can change
it back like this.
And, if you think
this is fake, then we
can actually look at the
different pixels here.
So let's switch it
back to red again.
And now, you have to be focused
because it will just flicker.
There you go.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
We can go back to
the presentation.
Thank you.
All right, so this
sounds amazing, right?
Firestore.
So why would anyone
choose another database
over Firestore?
Maybe Billy can
help us answer that.
BILLY JACOBSON: All
right, thanks, Daniel.
Glad it worked.
So yeah, all this
does look really good.
So that's kind of the first
case, where it's complex logic.
But if you're maybe more
in the data ingestion
intensive examples of
a use case for IoT,
you might need a
different solution.
So I've got a few
examples for us
look at that have
massive QPS requirements,
and solutions that are
going to work for them.
The first are going
to take a look at
is for Fleet
Monitoring, using IoT.
So let's say we are an
enterprise scale company that
wants to put some kind
of monitoring device
in a fleet of cars, or trucks.
We'd like to have a dashboard to
monitor our fleet in real time,
so we could detect anomalies
and provide feedback
to the drivers.
We'd also like to do the same
with the historical data.
Store that in the database
and potentially do
machine learning on it.
And maybe use that to optimize
the fleet, or use that
to train our data.
So if we translate these needs
into the business [INAUDIBLE]
the technical
requirements, we need
the horizontal scalability,
massive scale, low latency,
and high throughput.
And this is a perfect
fit for Cloud Bigtable.
Our massively scalable,
high throughput,
globally distributed,
NoSQL database service.
And this is the
same technology that
powers a range of billion
user Google services.
We've proven this to work
in search, maps, and Gmail.
And these are applications
that are getting millions
of database access per second.
And it's all happening
with low latency.
And if you're thinking a million
QPS is a slow day for you,
then you can just
increase the performance
by adding more Cloud
Bigtable nodes.
Throughput will scale linearly
based on the number of nodes.
So 30,000 QPS for three
nodes, or three million
QPS or 300 nodes.
Based on your performance
and cost requirements,
you can easily scale
with no downtime.
You don't have to
make a sacrifice
for consistent
throughput or latency
as your data size grows.
So we're going to take a
look at two examples, here.
It's examples of
Fleet Monitoring.
I've had a chance to work with
that, I think are pretty cool.
The first, were are going to
use the standard Bigtable API.
And then other, we'll use
the open source GeoMesa API.
So Cloud Bigtable provides a
ton of raw speed and scale,
but does it come with a trade?
This is a NoSQL solution.
And with that, there's a
very minimal query interface.
You can do row level
look-ups or row range scans.
So you must create a row key
that's going to group data
together based on the kinds
of queries you want to run.
For this example, we're looking
at monitoring the New York City
bus system.
And we want to focus on
individual bus lines over time.
So we're going to
create a key that's
a concatenation of the bus
line, the timestamp rounded down
to the hour, and
then the vehicle ID.
And for every data
point within that hour,
we can store them in the same
row using BigQuery tables
versioning feature.
So, with that, when
we perform a get row,
we're getting it
all the information
for a vehicle over the hour.
And you can see it kind of
going across Central Park.
But more commonly, we'd
probably use a scan.
And here, we're getting the
entire data set for this M86
select service bus line.
I'm looking at the heat map,
we already get a bit of data.
We can see where the starts
and stops of the bus are.
And maybe, if there
any slow points.
But if we want to get
even more information,
we could just append.
We could change our query
to have the bus line,
and maybe the timestamp
rounded up to the month.
And then see if that
changes over time.
We've have a code lab
with all this data
that works at the Bigtable API.
And we'll have a link
for that at the end,
if you want to play around
with this a little bit more.
So, now, we've seen
the Cloud Bigtable API.
But Bigtable also has Apache
HBase API compatibility.
So you get to use
that API if you're
more familiar with each base.
And more importantly,
this opens up
a ton of additional capabilities
for streaming, time series
analysis, and
geospatial analysis.
For some of these,
the additional APIs
will set up this
row key based schema
in a way that will maximize
Cloud Bigtable table's speed,
so you don't have to do that.
So, we're going to
take a look at GeoMesa.
And this creates a row key
using the latitude, longitude,
and timestamp to allow for
performance geospatial queries.
To use it, we change
our Dataflow job
to write features
using the Gmail API.
And then we're able to perform
more sophisticated queries
easily.
Here, I've got a query that's
selecting a bounding box
on a map and a time frame.
And I'm able to do this with
just a few lines of code.
So Daniel and I
worked with this team
at Google that would put air
quality sensors in the back
of Google Street View cars.
And we were able to stream their
data through our standard IoT
pipeline, and set up our
Dataflow job to write
to Bigtable using the mesa API.
We were able to create
a speedy dashboard
to view the cars as they
drove around San Francisco
in real time.
And batch process in three
years of historical data.
So we're seeing some of
that historical data now.
And these are just
some of the ways
you can use Cloud Bigtable
as part of your IoT pipeline.
Now, we're going to take a
look at one more IoT scenario,
and a database to
help out with it.
Here, we've got another large
scale organization that wants
to create public transit cards.
So users can tap their card
on the transit entrance,
which will remove money from
their card and let them enter.
And then if they
run out, they'll
have to go and refill that.
So this is a combination
of these IoT use cases.
We've got complex logic in here.
And this is also very
ingestion intensive.
So for the technical
requirements for this,
we need a horizontally
scalable system
to handle this massive scale
of a public transit system.
We need high
availability, so no is
going to have an issue
trying to get to their train.
And most importantly, we
need strong consistency,
since we're dealing with
monetary transactions.
And Google's offering
of Cloud Spanner
is a great fit for these.
It's the first horizontally
scalable, strongly consistent,
relational database service.
Daniel spoke a bit earlier
about consistency, availability,
partition tolerance,
as some of the things
you might have to choose
between when picking a database.
And with those databases,
you can only have two.
But Cloud Spanner
uses special hardware
to allow for all three.
And Cloud Spanner scales
similarly per node
like Cloud Bigtable, however,
to support transactions
with strong
consistency, writes are
going to be more computationally
expensive than writes
without strong consistency.
Since Bigtable doesn't
have strong consistency
amongst rows.
So Cloud Spanner can provide
up to 2,000 QPS of writes,
whereas Bigtable can provide
up to 10,000 QPS per writes.
But really, strong
consistency is
why that might be
a deciding factor
of using Spanner over Bigtable.
When you do decide to go
with Cloud Spanner though,
you get the benefits
of a relational and non
relational database.
On the relational side,
you get structure, schema,
and enforced data types.
As well as asset transactions
across rows, regions,
and continents.
And on the
non-relational side, you
get the horizontal scalability
of a NoSQL database.
If you're used to using a single
node solution with a master
replica setup, when that
system needs a software
update, security patch, or
any kind of maintenance,
you may have to take that
system down and have your user's
experience downtime.
We know your users
and your services
can have scheduled or
unscheduled downtime.
So because Spanner
is distributed,
we can move your data around
to perform routine maintenance
under the hood without
any visible changes to you
or your users.
Let's take a look
at how we might
use Spanner for this
public transit example.
We'll define a table
with using schema.
That should be pretty
familiar to any single users.
And then we can easily update
the schema with no downtime.
Here, we're creating a table
of commuters and their card
balances.
When we want to perform
a transaction on this,
we can first get the balance.
Then check it meets the
condition of being greater
than the cost of the fare,
and then deduct the cost
of the fare from the balance.
We've now taken a look
at three IoT scenarios.
And found databases
with particular strains
that complement the needs
of these applications.
But these examples
could generate
massive amounts of data.
So how do you perform
analytics across these ever
increasing data sets?
And Daniels got the
answer for that.
DANIEL BERGQVIST: Thank you.
So we usually divide databases
into OLTP or OLAP systems.
Analytical queries
usually need to scan over
huge number of records, and
calculate aggregate statistics.
Whereas transactional
queries usually
touch as a small number
of records fetched by key.
Our go to solution for ad
hoc analytical workloads
is BigQuery.
So anyone in here
familiar with BigQuery?
Cool.
So before we do
anything else, let's
do a super quick BigQuery demo.
Can we switch back the--
thank you.
So here, we have one
of the public data sets
that are published to BigQuery.
It's all the taxi
trips in New York--
well, there's several years--
but this particular year
is 2015.
And here, you can see the
different fields that we have,
and their data types.
So let's say I'm a data
scientist at the city of New
York, and I want
to just calculate
the number of taxi trips
per month during this year.
So this is how I would do that.
I'll use a timestamp
function that will,
I mean, it will focus
in with granularity.
This is the timestamp,
and it's the granularity.
So we want to pick month
from the timestamp.
And then we just count
the number of trips.
And then we group it by month.
So let's run this quick query.
This is not a very BigQuery,
it's probably, like,
around 150 million records.
And here, you see that you get
it's roughly around 12 million,
13 million taxi trips per month.
And if you want to visualize
this, it's super simple--
everything is a click away--
by just importing the
data into Data Studio.
So can we go back
to the presentation?
Thanks.
So BigQuery's serverless.
The underlying infrastructure
is being seamlessly managed
for you.
You just upload your
data to BigQuery,
or stream it into BigQuery.
And BigQuery them provides you
with a standards compliance SQL
interface, and off you go.
It also comes with
built in support
for geospatial and machine
learning capabilities.
Even those capabilities
are expressed through SQL.
BigQuery also has a
new feature called
BI Engine, which is a fast,
in memory analysis service.
Traditionally, when
you use BigQuery,
you get stable response times
between three to five seconds,
regardless, almost, of much
data your query is processing.
So, three to five
seconds, that's
great for a data scientist.
But for a dashboard, it
could be a little bit much.
So for the dashboard
we made might
want to have some
second latency,
and that's what BI
engine gives us.
BILLY JACOBSON: All
right, thanks, Daniel.
So, today, our intention isn't
to give you all the answers.
We want to empower you to know
how to choose a storage system.
So we looked at complex logic
applications, data ingestion
intensive applications,
and Daniel just
showed us how to perform We
see analytics on all of those.
So take this
knowledge and use it
to make an informed decision.
Don't treat storage
as an afterthought.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
DANIEL BERGQVIST: Billy
and I will be around,
if you want to chat
with us about this,
or any other storage
related topics.
BILLY JACOBSON: Yeah.
DANIEL BERGQVIST: Thanks.
[LOGO MUSIC]